hi everyone my name is kristen siverson
i'm a senior researcher at microsoft
research new england and i'm excited to
host our panel today on experiments
models inference and algorithms we'll be
discussing the importance of thinking
jointly about data generation and
computational approaches for biology and
healthcare applications
of each of our panelists quickly
introduce themselves and give a brief
summary of their lightning talk
if you haven't had a chance to watch
them yet i encourage you to go back
after this discussion and and watch each
one they're only 10 to 15 minutes long
and cover breadth of topics in this area
um so without further ado let's start
with ava and go around the virtual room
thanks kristin hi everyone my name is
ava sloimani i'm a senior researcher at
microsoft research new england
and in my talk i explore how uncertainty
in machine learning methods can be used
as a bridge to
interface experimental and computational
work
and i specifically focus on molecular
modeling and drug discovery as an
exemplary use case for this approach and
share how we developed a novel algorithm
for uncertainty estimation in deep
learning models and applied it in this
setting
hi everyone
i'm fei chen i'm a faculty member at the
broad institute and also at harvard in
my talk i talked about some technologies
that we're developing in the lab
that are experimental technologies that
allow us to bridge genomics with spatial
information about tissues
i go into a little bit about how this
technology works experimentally what the
data is like and as well as like the
computational approaches
and some some ml-based approaches that
we use to
extract information about where cell
types live and how they interact
hi my name is jabron zahid and i'm a
researcher at microsoft research in
redmond i am working in the immunomax
group on the antigen map project we are
engaged in a bold collaboration with
adaptive biotechnologies to try and
learn how to reap that human human
immune system
we take next generation sequencing of
the t cell repertoire of individuals and
based on that try to understand
and develop diagnostics for diseases
they may have and may have had
previously
hi everyone my name is noemi el haddad
i'm an associate professor
in biomedical informatics at columbia
university
and in my talk i describe a project that
we've been doing with endometriosis
patients
the issue there is that there's a dearth
of data and there's a very large
disconnect between what's known
clinically and what patients experience
and so we built
we've done a very long detour to get to
collect data that represents the patient
experience and that can be used to be
augmenting clinical and surgical data
and understand better the disease
great thanks everyone we're so grateful
for you taking the time to be here with
us today
um so to get our conversation started
ava i thought that your talk had a
really nice summary of the promise of
machine learning in biomedicine along
with some of the current needs um so i
was hoping you could kick off our
discussion by summarizing those points
here and
in all of these conversations everybody
else please feel free to jump in with
additional comments
sure yeah so
i think you know part of the reason why
we're all here today is because we're
excited about this possibility for
machine learning to really make a
transformative impact in biology and
healthcare and i think as we've already
started to see that you know
has been true for a number of different
application areas from diagnostics uh to
you know personalized health monitoring
to therapeutic design to fundamental
biological discovery
but i think one of the outstanding
challenges that sort of unites and
unifies all these different application
areas is the fact that in biology in
clinical sciences
there's
this really strong link to
experimentation and to interfacing with
humans who are you know in the clinic at
the bench generating data and putting
models and algorithms to the test
and it's that interface that i think
brings a lot of particular challenges um
that are
still not totally solved and are are
really ripe
for opportunity in terms of developing
new advances that can sort of accelerate
the potential of machine learning for
this field
yeah absolutely i think we can all
definitely agree that like having good
data for these problems is really key to
any project's success and kind of given
that uh knowing me i'm interested to
learn a bit more about the history of
the app you developed whether or not at
the outset you intended to need to do
that much data collection and kind of
what
experiences you you've learned from that
that you think might generalize to other
projects in in the bio and health spaces
yeah i think we we kind of tried to
uh think in a very you know we tried to
plan this and and think about what type
of experiments would we want to run uh
together with participants with patients
and think about what type of
infrastructure would we want to put
together where we could collect data but
also
intervene and communicate with patients
directly
how much um how much would we want to
ask them and
then the constraints come in in terms of
you know you can't ask
someone a research participant for every
single thing that is happening in their
lives and so um
then we we kind of went back to very
like basic human computer interaction
principles and and thinking of usability
of of this app
and
user friendliness of the app all the
while thinking about um you know what
kind of experimentation and computation
we could do about it after but the the
big question throughout and until we got
to do our uh you know we collected
enough data was like
how much of a bias are we introducing
when we are asking uh participants to
self-track and not uh giving them a
trill a strong schedule of participation
or anything like that it's very much
like a regular app that some people are
excited to use and others are less you
know more lenient and less adherent
about and um
and and that was you know always on the
forefront in terms of modeling again how
would we if we identify this as a bias
how would we mitigate it
yeah so i guess i'm curious to hear from
faye because you've also been developing
technology to gather data but with a
clearly very different set of users than
uh noemi's project and so i don't know
if any of the points she was making
resonated with you if you could talk a
little bit about how the way you've
designed slide seek is is different or
similar
yeah um i think you know thinking about
a little bit uh about just the
interplay the challenges of bringing ml
to biology is that
you know we're just getting to the point
in biology where we can collect
when people think about large data sets
in biology
i think they're talking about a very
different thing
than when people usually think about
large data in ml um
and
um it's only recently with kind of like
the
super exponential scaling of the cost of
sequencing
are we even starting to collect
like
biological data sets
um
i think that that are very amenable to
like ml based approaches um at least on
gene expression and on sequencing um
obviously imaging is another area in
biology where we we do have access to a
lot of data although um
there you know there are some caveats
there that we can think about as well
but but in general like you know um one
challenge is just collecting the
requisite amount of data necessary uh to
you know like leverage really good ml
based approaches uh and i actually think
that we're only just starting to get get
there and
um
and part of developing technologies we
think about at least my lab we think
about like how scalable is the
technology and how do we design it to be
really light scalable and accessible to
a lot of folks uh and also
um we really like technologies which
leverage sequencing readouts because
i i believe that the cost of sequencing
is going to continue to decrease maybe
exponentially and so
um there is another opportunity to start
generating data at a different scale
yeah so jabron my understanding is your
project also really leverages sequencing
from an
immunology perspective i'm curious about
how
you've gotten people excited about that
work or engage with participants in
order to build the data sets that that
your analysis leverages
yeah i i think we're
in a slightly different regime where i
don't think we're currently data limited
we've been beneficiary of being able to
collect data uh for some time now to the
point where i think what's limiting us
is ideas uh our understanding our
fundamental understanding of the biology
uh but
in terms of um getting people excited to
participate i would say as an example uh
what we did what happened with covid was
a watershed movement we were able to we
built a diagnostic
for covid uh based on collaborations
with both public uh
academic and um
private industry partners
and we're able to use that the urgency
of the situation to really push our
understanding of how we can learn to
read the immune system of humans and so
i think part of it is just the urgency
of the situation we're in our strategy
has been to tackle diseases that are
particularly difficult to diagnose and
therefore we've had lots of partners
that are very forthcoming uh academic
and private
so no no i mean i'm interested to hear
then how that's been with your
experience because i'm i continue to be
surprised with how prevalent
endometriosis is and
like meanwhile uh seems relatively
understudied so how has your experience
been in engaging participants um
in your
work
yeah and i i'm i'm really resonating
with what javon said which is that when
you when you focus on some diseases that
are like where there's this clear need
uh an urgency you definitely you know
people respond with more enthusiasm and
i think what we found with endometriosis
patients was that they were dying to get
heard and
there's this theme in patient
communities about like
this you know having their voices being
uh ignored by the health care system and
not getting to a diagnosis in time and
so suddenly when a researcher comes and
says we'd love to know everything about
you so that we can somehow get to others
to get to a diagnosis it really
resonated with with people and and so
we've been we've been feeling very
grateful about um about the interest
that it that it had and and also why we
kind of chose this
this principle of citizen science as a
way to present the research to the
to the participants and and it worked i
think very well in our focus groups with
patients uh you know we would ask them
why would you want to use such an app
and and they all had even a persona in
mind of like you know there's a teenage
girl somewhere who's suffering and i
don't want her to go through what i went
through and so i think it you know when
you have this nice alignment with
reasons to participate in science and
it's
it becomes uh easy um where it gets
harder and we need to like bring in and
keep thinking about like how can
technology help us is
in the type of data we're trying to
collect we want like repeated measures
through time and it's a it's a lot to
ask to any human i mean i myself i don't
want to use my app every day you know
like it's hard to get to stay motivated
and so i think
then you want to think of other
engagement techniques basically uh to to
keep getting the right type of data
yeah
so i want to move a little bit to kind
of a different end of the ml pipeline
and ask abba about her experience in
developing these uncertainty techniques
and
kind of
given that you're now characterizing the
output of a model as opposed to thinking
about the data that's input
like what do you think are some of the
major gaps or importance of that that
part of the pipeline as well
yeah i think that's a fantastic question
um
and
definitely i would say at a high level
you know as we've seen there's there's a
need to
kind of have a link right between the
data collection and the predictive
outputs themselves but where uncertainty
can come in
is by
you know giving the user the end user
the human a sense of when the model's
predictions may not be able to be
trusted and that's often very very much
linked to
the quality of data that you know is in
a particular
space
in the sense that we know that machine
learning models tend to
have
poor predictive performance on
you know out of distribution data
um or data that has not been seen as
frequently by the model and that's going
to be associated with a higher metric of
predictive uncertainty and so those two
components are very directly linked
and i think where the potential for
uncertainty really lies is in being able
to give some feedback
to the you know the biologist the end
user to say okay here's a region of the
of our data landscape that is perhaps
underrepresented underexplored
it could be worthwhile to collect more
data in this region or to focus
experimental efforts
you know on hypotheses that can
can test
yeah it can contest ideas that are
relevant to that space and so there i
think that's
uh really telling as to how uncertainty
in particular can try to bridge this
divide and link predictions back to data
and iterate from there
yeah and it sounds like no no i mean you
were tackling some similar potential
issues in your work when you were
worried about the the biases that might
be introduced by the the data collection
methods wondering if you could talk a
little bit more about about your
experience in analyzing and then
potentially mitigating those effects
yeah um and so so specifically you know
in our case because someone is
self-tracking on an app uh you know some
might be self-tracking more than others
and there could be an imbalance from one
person to the next
um we also in in a similar type of
situations we're doing predictive
modeling on menstrual trackers uh which
is again like some you know some
individuals tracking a time series
basically and sometimes forgetting to
track that you know and so there's this
difference between the true state and
what we observe and we are trying to
disentangle the two and so what we found
was that um you know we
it it was very useful to
have both for example in our predictive
modeling have a way of predict uh
predicting for example next period uh
date but also have at the same time have
a latent variable about that tells us
how likely is it that someone is have
forgotten to track and and really like
explicitly separating these two things
uh from one another i think the other
you know the big difference when it
comes to like these places where you
have control or an ability to interact
with the user is uh very similar to what
ava is saying on
um
you know we're also looking into for
example just in time intervention jedi
like reinforcement learning where you
know we know enough about someone's uh
trajectory and we can tell them here's a
thing you could try for your pain or
something like that but we also know
that if we don't have uh enough data we
won't have good predictions and so
having this ability to to model again
like how much is missing
rather than the thing that you're really
interested in modeling which is like how
is your pain how's your state
you can uh you can maybe have an
intervention that is about
we really need more data right now are
you willing to tell us a little bit more
about what's going on and then move on
to you know the real prediction later
yeah that's really neat i think the idea
of being able to to ask for the data you
need is is a pretty novel thing that i
haven't haven't seen in a lot of
applications
well thinking about uncertainty bias
maybe generalizability kind of fits
right in that that category jabron i was
impressed in the analysis you showed how
well the model extended across different
populations and locations and i was
curious if you felt like the team did
anything in particular to get that
result or if you have any tips on
how to improve generalizability when you
have data sets coming from different
sources
yeah i think you know one of the things
is we were the beneficiary of having a
relatively large data set as far as it
goes
uh in terms of diseases we had several
thousand individuals that were made up
our case set for covid and i think that
helped significantly in fact early on
when we were
developing the model the earlier stages
of it we encountered issues of
generalizability which were directly
related to the lack of representation of
people of certain genetic backgrounds
within our data sets we had a sample
from padova in italy which just didn't
work there was many more false positives
than we had seen another situation in
our model in general and we quickly
learned that you know it was a
consequence of the genetic background
variation and one of the lessons we took
away from that is okay you may not be
able to solve for that problem because
we don't have data from all over the
globe but can we at least diagnose it as
an issue and that led to us building
some infrastructure that we regularly
check now which
genetic backgrounds do we do well for
um and so
um
i think you know that sort of
checking of biases is critical because
we're not talking about you know
figuring out what's whether something's
a cat or a dog we're talking about human
health right and so if we're applying
these complex models to human health we
better
know
if we're having uh we're introducing
biases as a consequence of those models
definitely it makes a lot of sense um i
want to pivot to one other topic
and it's a question for faye because i
think that one of the exciting promises
of biology and health is this ability to
integrate many different types of data
sets and you alluded to it at the end of
your talk using different sequencing
techniques along with side slide seek
and maybe demographic variables or what
have you so i'm curious if you give us a
sense of what you think are like some of
the major limitations as to why we
haven't achieved that and like what some
of the
future algorithmic needs might be
yeah i i think that's an area of like
quite exciting research actually that's
a great question um
in genomics i mean there's lots and lots
of folks working on algorithms which try
to integrate many different modalities
um
and um
in general um
we've we've had certain success with
certain classes of problems uh and and
basically
the the classes the the types of things
that that we're successful for like we
can like regress we can like kind of
remove batch effects from data
collection right we can if there's like
many different
um if we're observing the same
biological phenomenon but with different
modalities of measurement like
uh you know there's some intrinsic
you know underlying
like space that cells behave in and we
observe it by rnac and we observe it by
imaging and we observe it by uh you know
um epigenetic sequencing we're actually
becoming quite good at integrating those
data sets to like
project them on top of each other
because like we're learning like
different looks the same amount of like
variation in in the population so so
they're like uh
integrating like multiple modalities
information um
we're actually getting quite good tools
for
i think
um
the challenge is that we have a lot of
different data sets where
um you're not exactly looking at the
same thing right you could have like a
lot of like demographic variability
in addition or like genetic variability
in addition to
kind of
um you know modalities of information
and i think that that actually is a
pretty outstanding problem it's hard to
integrate those data sets together
because
um you're not observing some like latent
variable uh across these different
modalities there's actually other
sources of variation and so so uh but i
think that would be really valuable
right like we can't always collect the
same you know genetic background data
you know from across every different
modality or like you know um
or across diseases even right so i think
that that that is that is one challenge
would be a great area of tech
development for folks who are interested
yeah definitely i think that type of
multi-view learning is an exciting area
um well we're almost out of time so i
wanted to kind of wrap up our discussion
by talking about
advice you might have for people who are
excited about this field i i imagine a
lot of people tuning in to our
discussion or those who are you know
excited about machine learning and
biology and health and might be looking
for ways to get involved or problems
that might be exciting to tackle so i'm
curious if if you guys could give some
some advice to those folks
okay i'll start i i think i for me i
think coming from natural language
processing and machine learning
my my expectation in going into health
was like
experimental data is wonderful but will
not be the answer uh because we need
scale and we need uh you know well many
reasons and i think like what i you know
with the years i mellowed a little bit
but i think the advice is that there's
there's value to each type of data set
and and this idea of um
trying to have a holistic view of health
cannot be only through observational
data set or only through experimental
data or only this method or that method
and so being a little like soup to nuts
in your approach
is probably
the right thing to do
to have a better understanding of or a
better arsenal of tools and techniques
and data to answer basic questions
one piece of advice i have for anyone
doing any machine learning i think it's
a very general which is
and and it's especially
critical in the context of human health
is that you need to start with simple
approaches
uh
the key is you have to understand what
you're doing it's quite easily it quite
commonly happens that people have this
large data set they throw a model at it
they get a great prediction out the
other side and then they're happy and
they stop and you just can't do that in
human health because there's too much on
the line and you really need to
understand what your model's doing you
can't treat it as a black box so
really i think the approach that i've
taken is you start with the simplest
models and you try to understand the
actual
mechanisms by which you know the model
itself is working and how those
mechanisms tied to the fundamental
science
of whatever problem it is you're working
on in human health
yeah i
okay i totally agree with devron's point
about always starting with the simplest
model i think in practice for me this is
also a strategy that i regularly employ
um
i think it's a good
good principle to live by in general for
anyone who's doing machine learning the
other thing that i'll add on to that is
so i came from
a
my phd in my phd training i did both
experimental wet lab work and
computational work and that has been
that has been particularly valuable to
sort of understand the day-to-day the
nitty-gritty of what it takes to get
stuff done in the wet lab and to build
up a technology and move that technology
to the point of you know being ready to
be put into practice in the clinic or
used by other researchers and so
i think because of that intimate
understanding of what
you know biological experimentation
takes it's it's made me have a
unique perspective and a greater
appreciation for where machine learning
can fit in and where it's just not yet
ready to fit in and so having that um
having that perspective has been really
valuable and
you know i think it's
as we're seeing people come up and in
their training at the interface of these
two fields
will be really cool to see how you know
people's trajectories progress and how
the field grows as a result of that
yeah i was actually going to say
something very similar to you
i i i think it's
uh you know i'm an experimentalist
so and i think it's actually really
valuable
[Music]
when you build and it's similar to what
javon said it's like
when you're building your models it's
really valuable to go back and forth to
iterate like back and forth with people
generating the data right to get
a lot of feedback about both how your
model is working and also like
you know what are what are the areas
wherein the model is you know
underperforming um
and also just getting an intuition for
how the data the structure of the data
and how it works how it's collected it's
not like uh you know a black box where
the data is just coming out right and so
i i think that's actually really
valuable
and has been valuable for the students
that have worked at that intersection in
my group
great thank you all so much i really
appreciate you taking the time today and
uh discussing these topics with us um
definitely looking forward to hearing
more about your future work
thank you
thank you nice to meet everybody